I started before finance was even a real
discipline so there wasn't anything
rittany journals in finance or anything
like that so everything was new at that
time and it took a while initially
before it made its way into practice but
then it was kind of like a explosion
waterfall it took maybe ten or fifteen
years before initially the applied world
the investment world came around to the
new way of thinking but then when they
did now it's basically instant so
they're they're looking over our
shoulders all the time and now to see
what's going on and see how they can
incorporate it into their their product
so finance is really very applied as a
as a discipline the research gets
applied very quickly if it works if it
has anything to say